de confusion d'abord laissé le soin à
une personne en relation avec son
prédécesseur
la dame a finalement c'était à l'issue
de cette réunion du front national
augmente parti dirigé par le pc
tchécoslovaque
il a fêté les pauses son temps
l'ex-premier ministre essayait
désespérément de fournir à nouveau
gouvernement mais en lâchant le mois de
l'ess possible tous les chèques étaient
malgré tout près d'ici l'été ce biais
dans une allocution télévisée
il avait menacé de démissionner
l'accession populaire et elle a tenu le
fort en belgique n'a pas calmé le jeu
la patronne de l'opposition dans les
rangs du parti communiste on envoie ce
n'était qu'à travers bien sûr de régine
missions de plus en plus délicate qu'on
sait désormais à marianne khalfa premier
ministre par intérim ne met pas le
président christophe fiat considéré
comme un réformateur il ya déjà négocié
des bananes est la formation qui ce
premier gouvernement de lula sur
concernés cette fois-ci minecraft
orateurs verra comprenait entre les
desiderata bessat et des zooms quoi
qu'il en soit pratique qui ne connaîtra
pas de nouveau gouvernement avec l'ex
premier décroissance à la conclusion
aussi à l'allemagne de l'est
les autorités ont lancé aujourd'hui un
appel dramatique pas critiquer la
population pour la mettre en oeuvre
contre les risques ni
la population le chef du labour du
conseil européen placée sous le double
signe de l'unité monétaire et de la
réunification allemande
si vous êtes en direct du palais des
congrès à strasbourg les difficultés
pressenties dans le camp
citation qui doit préparer et économique
d'une personne taxes est important c'est
que nous avons des positions
l'année prochaine le problème de la
réunification
chez certains partenaires
effectivement il ya des partenaires qui
en particulier faire quelques pas
depuis trop longtemps le rond central
le gouvernement est bien perçu et qui va
falloir apprendre à préparer soutenir le
rapport demain et c'est pas des fonds
nécessaires
c'est tellement d'accord avec le
gouvernement dénéral conférence spéciale
consacrée traite ces problèmes très
complexes et qui tentent d'intégrer
aussi des pays comme la grande bretagne
jusqu'à présent sont restés très
réticents une conférence qu'il est
réellement la fin de l'année prochaine
après les élections générales
leur souci majeur l'unité enjeu
politique de taille pour l'opposition
réunification ce qu'il laisse entendre
que nous donnions revenir à certains
paquets du métro dit nationale
et c'est précisément ce que nous voulons
pas nous voulons aller de l'avant vers
un amour où les frontières entre la
république fédérale allemande attend
l'unité de l'europe de toute l'europe
même si elle ne prend qu'une autre
c'est dramatique ce n'est pas moi qu'il
faut peut-être pas la question parce que
c'est un échec pour l'europe et pour 30
minutes avant la conclusion d'un second
cliché à peu la même chose que n'a pas
confirmée je vais à présent mal comment
d'aussi bonne qualité
alors là les choses ont changé ces
dernières années les coups que j'ai
cliqué je n'ai même voie mais c'est
qu'elle présentait d'autres reportages
et d'autres commentaires incertain
l'horreur hier en fin d'après midi dans
les locaux de l'université de montréal
en quelques minutes un jeune corse n'est
plus quatorze jeunes filles et des 13
autres personnes avant de se suicider
dans une lettre retrouvée sur lui le
meurtrier avec exprimer sa haine
nous avons décidé nous même de rejoindre
les casernes au sein de la rébellion
tous les a jugés trop kaboré derniers
jours dans les gènes du tri de manille
désormais seul aéroport routiers mis au
centre du pays il est encore aux mains
des rebelles
en une semaine les affrontements ont
fait 81 morts et 200 blessés
52 morts 400 blessés ces derniers dès
lors de l'énorme et régions qui avait
basculé hier le quartier général de la
police politique
les autorités colombiennes ont attribué
cet attentat aux soldes mains des
trafiquants de drogue chez l'extradition
vers les états unis
c'est bien sûrs d'ailleurs revendiqué ce
soir là quand à la bombe contre l'avion
d'avianca qui avait fait 107 morts il ya
dix jours dans une intervention à la
télévision le président turquie au parc
a rappelé du n'y avait pas d'office du
tour le pays que de poursuivre une lutte
intransigeante contre les
narcotrafiquants pour lui les soirs de
la présence des travailleurs ni
prisonnier réputé semblait difficile de
certain temps parce que favorable pour
aujourd'hui questions notamment sur la
relance de la prison la maison centrale
de lannemezan abrite des détenus
condamnés à des peines de longue durée
l'un des évadés et d'ailleurs condamné à
perpétuité hier soir donc 17h30 derrière
ses murs la séance de sport sa chaîne
les détenus qui avaient bien préparé
leur affaire est à l'action
ils franchissent un mur à l'intérieur de
la centrale plus un procès arrive au
mirador qu'ils en ont sauté la force
avec du plastique de l'explosif
les évadés travers ce petit bois à une
centaine de mètres de la prison dans
cette cité il s'empare d'une bx e puis
ensuite 205 auto-écoles montée fuyard
est blessé qui va se rendre à un
kilomètre de là la crise du plateau pour
se faire soigner
de nouveau ils s'enfuient lorsque
l'infirmière lui donnant
dans le même temps l'un des évadés rp à
lannemezan en pleine ville à deux pas de
la gendarmerie
ce sont des gardiens de la maison
centrale qui n'était pas en service
s'ils reconnaissent dans la rue et qui
vont le remettre aux gendarmes
depuis 24 heures tous les renseignements
recueillis par policiers et gendarmes
sont systématiquement vérifiées alors à
se poser bien sûr le problème des
responsabilités et cette question simple
comment peut-on détenir du plastique et
s'évader de l'un des endroits le mieux
gardé en france
la mémoire des épisodes douloureux de
l'histoire en question réussi dans la
roue et déclenché une polémique autour
de la vente d'une maison symbole maison
en 1944 44 enfants juifs avaient retenu
avant d'être déportés et de nourrir dans
le camp des îles le ventre de cette
maison plus de 2 millions de francs
beaucoup trop ça comme le texte qui
souhaitent créer le musée mémorial de la
déportation
le propriétaire lui même entendre à la
maison d'izieu là où 44 enfants juifs
avaient trouvé refuge avant d'être
déportée sur l'ordre de klaus barbie
l'association souhaite l'acquérir pour
la transformer en maison du souvenir
l'acheter mais pas à n'importe quel prix
la bâtisse est destiné à un million
trois cent mille francs or sa
propriétaire affirme avoir trouvé
meilleur acteur
les responsables de l'association pour
le musée critique alors c'est à quévert
qui s'est il ou non
selon la propriétaire l'acheteur inconnu
de conclure la terre samedi
s'agit-il d'une manoeuvre pour tenter de
faire grimper les prix une seule
certitude aujourd'hui aucun compromis
n'a encore été signé par les romances
après la série de restrictions de
circulation dans les grandes rencontres
à cet effet elle les maires concernés
afin de modifier les professionnels
compétents par des mesures
l'instituteur c'est par une forte odeur
de gaz dans la présence dans le corps
totalement paralysé
chacune des compétitions européennes
c'est l'exploit des champions et
maintenant le club tenant du titre
étranger par le werder de brême 5-1
maradona et demi qu'on n'a pu empêcher
la déroute de son équipe et du gardien
souligne annie deux fois noté par les
allemands de l'est zaoual cinq ans et la
plus lourde défaite de nathan cullen en
blanc attendu la dernière minute la
qualification face à l'étoile rouge de
belgrade sur cette talonnade lors de nos
colonnes en quarts de finale
troisième club allemand qualifié en boum
merkel ouvre le score pour les blancs
pour tous va quand même l'emporter 2 1
un score insuffisant malgré son superbe
but de la tête inscrit par le jeune
georges courtès trois buts sur le
terrain de liège et comme dans le même
temps nous marronne le gardien liégeois
les sièges décroche sa qualification de
faire sans la fiorentina il s'agit même
plus sont encore en course
les turinois sont imposés plaisir à
carnac
sur un coup franc de l'aria
internationale uci d'agostini grands
partis politiques